death stranding is finally here from the
beginning Hideo Kojima's latest game has
been shrouded in mystery from a baby
giving us a thumbs up to Norman Reedus
his entire ass
the initial trailers left us confused
but wanting more
there's no denying yet death stranding
is a trippy game to celebrate its
release we've come up with a list of the
five trickiest games to enjoy after
you've gotten a taste of the strange
unconventional game that is death
stranding Metal Gear Solid 2 Sons of
Liberty at first Metal Gear Solid 2 just
seemed like a quality sequel to 1998
Metal Gear Solid there were familiar
faces its gameplay and storyline are
similar and Metal Gear still needs to be
stopped but just as you grow comfortable
with your mission and ride in the story
flips on its head after you learn about
the Patriots and their control over
global information your mission goes
from saving the president from dead cell
to destroying a government built AI that
controls the flow of information
information that directly involves you
on your mission the twists and turns
this story pulls you through our Ward
winning and will have you questioning
every action you make and every plot
point in the story by the time you feel
like you know all there is to know the
story throws another curveball
continually making you feel like a pawn
upon completing the game you feel
mentally awakened and broken at the same
time only to be treated by a cliffhanger
post-credit scene they're already dead
all 12 of them when did it happen
about a hundred years ago Bioshock the
story of Bioshock is as memorable as it
is freaky the twisted plot constantly
plays with your expectations giving you
a false sense of control and purpose as
you navigate the underwater city of
Rapture you learn more about its
disturbing past and fall from grace you
discover a city plagued by corruption
genetic mutation and a warped philosophy
and with no contact from the surface
world your only encounters are with the
terrifying inhabitants of Rapture
splicers big daddies and little sisters
these genetically altered beings are the
products of a disturbing series of
events that unfolds and grows all the
more intriguing the further
progress which ultimately leads to one
of the most shocking endings in modern
videogames eternal darkness sanity's
requiem in 2002 the Nintendo GameCube
was gifted a strange little exclusive
that bent the rules of survival horror
by breaking the fourth wall in a number
of unique ways it made you vulnerable
through your playthrough not just from
the unsettling story but from some of
its deceptive in-game mechanics when
encountering enemies the game will trick
you in numerous ways including falsely
ending the game pretending to delete
save files and even blue screen in your
game this can be prevented by keeping
the game sanity meter in check but if it
drops near enemies these disorienting
effects make it hard for you to focus
the on-screen character will start to
audibly panic and the effects will start
to take place even with no enemies
present the entire experience makes you
and the character feel insane and no
longer in control this unique feeling of
helplessness and terror is one that will
always make this game stand out not only
in the GameCubes library but in all
video games amnesia the Dark Descent on
the surface amnesia the Dark Descent may
just seem like a streamer friendly good
time but this indie survival horror game
messes with your head like few others
can your journey begins in a dark castle
where you have no memory of the past
events the darkness surrounding you
quickly becomes your main enemy this
game's plot is fragmented making you
rebuild your memory by way of journal
entries written by your character Daniel
you roam around in the darkness without
a weapon hoping to uncover the truth of
your past quickly before going
completely insane or getting jumpscared
what results is an otherworldly plot
including interdimensional beings
torture and a mysterious mind
controlling orb since the games 2010
launch its impact on indie survival
horror games cannot be ignored
Silent Hill the original Silent Hill
pulls no punches with its delusional
story immediately after the opening
scene you are thrown into a world
created by nightmares as you search for
your daughter in the fog-covered town
you'll meet others along the way only to
end up with more questions than answers
it carries themes of death greed rebirth
and fear alongside many others the
terrifying enemies you face are
manifestations of these themes that
represent the darker side of human
psyche and society as a whole silent
hill's tone and psychological story
carry over into its gameplay it's dark
you always feel lost and you witness
it's disturbing themes come to life if
you want an ordinary survival horror
title look elsewhere because Silent Hill
will mess with your head unlike any
other this was only a handful some of
our favorite trickiest games so in the
comments let us know which are some of
your favorites thanks for watching
you